[Music]
this is the time where you're a junior
and the photographer tells you let's go
to the beach take some pictures and
you're like sure let's do it and you
think you're like this good-looking cool
dude and later on you'll regret it but I
laugh at it and death look you can pull
off I would wear it again and it's I
guess Anna Wintour this is I think the
time when I started to take chances so
you see it's a very shiny jacket
it's risky I don't think I've worn in
ever since but I would wear it again
Anna gave me a lot of confidence it's
okay to make mistakes you know but just
you're gonna kind of appreciate it and
embrace it I think it's a nice I'm
trying to figure out my hair on a daily
basis it's doing its own thing feel like
I'm in an ongoing transformation with my
hair because it's always been more or
less the same length and you get tired
of it too it's right this way that way
backwards full its adventure you just
start making a lot of mistakes as well
like this for me out in that I like
jackets you know and I think it's a good
jacket yeah this is an ASA I thought
maybe turtleneck with a suit not
everybody likes the turtleneck I'm not
the biggest fan
always of it either but I think you
gotta wear his confidence I even said
you know what we're going all out I even
put the sunglasses on which I rarely do
I think it's an ace come on it looks a
little bit like superstar kind of thing
I'm like okay let's go whether it's fine
I still think I have this suit I like
suits so this is a nice you know what my
favorite moment is it seems like I'm in
a studio if I will maybe walk around
like this at 20 years old it's a like
fine
but you don't take a studio picture shot
like this it feels like I'm trying hard
on the hair I wouldn't wear this again
but hey no regrets it's it's all good
it's still a fault though
if you don't try you don't know and I
will ensure about it when I put it on
because I was sort of requested to put
on white jeans and a jacket and I was
like okay let me try it let me see how
the white jeans are gonna look and I
actually think it's an ace I think it
looks good I don't know what to think of
this one this was like the comfy period
I wanted to just feel comfortable I
would still wear something like this so
it's an ace to me but a fault to wear it
with my French Open trophy I feel like I
should have done better